and here we go again the latest set
another set of documents marked
classified this time found at the home
of former vice president Mike Pence
after a search that he requested to
catch you up two special counsels are
already investigating former president
Trump and President Biden's handling of
classified materials and now there are
calls for a wider inquiry into how
officials are keeping track of these
items or as it happens not keeping track
of them Ed O'Keefe is at the White House
for us add laugh cry I don't know how to
feel good morning Good morning Tony look
today the head of the nation's
intelligence agencies is already
scheduled to be on Capitol Hill for a
series of briefings and she is sure to
get an earful from Democrats and
Republicans concerned about the security
of classified documents how they're
tracked and whether any of the nation's
top secrets are at risk
I kind of thought holy heck members of
both parties are demanding answers after
yet another high office holder may have
mishandled classified documents what the
hell is going on around here is my
reaction you know look obviously there's
a systemic problem in the executive
branch this time it's about a dozen
documents Mark classified found at the
Indiana home of former vice president
Mike Pence in letters sent to the
National Archives lawyers for Pence say
they searched his home last week out of
an abundance of caution following
reports about documents found at
President Biden's Delaware home they
discovered a number of documents with
classified markings and put them in a
safe until FBI agents came to collect
them two weeks ago Pence assured CBS
news that he didn't take any documents
with him when he left office our staff
reviewed all of the materials
in our office and in our residence to
ensure that there were no classified
materials that that left the White House
or remained in our possession attorney
general Merrick Garland has already
appointed special counsels to probe the
classified documents cases of former
president Donald Trump and President
Biden but wouldn't comment on Pence
Tuesday and at the Capitol lawmakers say
they've got to act to help prevent
future missteps maybe we're over
classifying things that may be part of
the problem but count me in for getting
this fixed I think we find that they're
rushing Larry Pfeiffer is a former White
House National Security official he
thinks the typical chaos at the end of a
presidency may have played a role
they're not going through every page of
every document representatives for
former presidents Barack Obama George W
bush and Bill Clinton tell CBS news that
all documents classified and
unclassified were handed over to the
National Archives when they left office
but Pfeiffer says the former commanders
in Chief and their top deputies might
want to check again if I was a former
president or former vice president I'd
be having teams scouring every nook and
cranny
now President Biden had no comment when
we tried shouting questions at him again
yesterday about this but AIDS here at
the White House are somewhat relieved
that it's now longer just the current
and former president facing potential
political and legal Fallout as for
former president Trump he used his own
social media platform yesterday to
defend Mike Pence calling him an
innocent man and he said quote leave him
alone Nate
seems like every time we talk to you
classified documents are popping up
everywhere Ed thank you